I think they got a special coming up
tonight do you have a special tonight on
the vertical we do Dan a a very special
on the heels of our our draft show which
was a pretty big success for doing a
free agency special that begins at
eleven thirty eastern and goes probably
past 1am as these deals start to come in
and you can stream that at a vertical
com do you think they'll be deals
announced at midnight 1201 tonight
absolutely I think they'll be maybe not
1201 per se but within the first 20
minutes of of the the deadline passing I
think some deals that seem like
no-brainers at the moment are Andre
Drummond in Detroit Bradley Beal in
Washington I think there's a decent
chance Nick Batum in charlotte could
agree to something at some point Al
Horford in Atlanta's one to watch will
Atlanta pony up the cash in a five-year
deal to make out happy if they do that
could get done pretty quickly pretty big
names come off the board very fast all
right Kevin Durant's plan meeting with
everybody in the Hamptons now nobody
else is the Knicks and lakers can't get
an audience here with Kevin Durant the
Lakers definitely not the Knicks not at
this point I wonder if the expected
signing of Joakim Noah goes through if
that'll change if he decides to rent
that is on Sunday morning that he's okay
with giving Phil Jackson and Jeff
hornacek and Carmelo who he's been
talking to a lot of this last week an
audience but as of right now the teams
that are out there that you've seen are
the ones on it was most likely to happen
what's the scenario with Durant that you
know even some of the executives that
I've talked to or even players that I've
talked to that are going to be in the
room it are the expectation is that
oklahoma city remains a strong favorite
you know the one-year deal
to return to the Thunder and effectively
punt on free agency until the summer of
2017 what a lot of other big names are
on the market and the money goes up even
higher he's be the most likely scenario
but the one the one caveat Saul this dan
is that when you get in a room with
Durant you know things could change very
rapidly you look back at last year and a
LaMarcus Aldridge situation I would
argue that alters went into free agency
thinking he was going to be a Los
Angeles Laker well the Lakers came in
they packed the meeting they did mildly
better on the second one but they
immediately came off the Marcuse's list
I would bet you that that the Phoenix
Suns at the start of it were never going
to be on the Marcus Aldridge list they
became a finalist towards the end
alongside San Antonio so what these guys
get in the room and specifically the
players last year was Tyson Chandler
trying to recruit LaMarcus Aldridge the
Phoenix if you get say golden state
which is which I'm told is sending
draymond Green Steph Curry and klay
Thompson ought to this meeting with
kevin durant why those three guys in the
room along with the Steve Kerr anything
you kind of happened there so I think
Oklahoma City's up a front-runner but
it's the ultimate fluid situation okay
but Golden State is sending their three
best players into the Hamptons Friday
morning ah well yes but they're meeting
is Friday yeah that's what they're doing
Oh they've been recruiting him all
season long no Chris they have been
recruiting you're saying yes yeah well
look Golden State the players have Steph
Steph has been trying to recruit he and
clay been trying to recruit Kevin all
season long yeah I don't think there's
any doubt but the same way Carmelo has
been doing it in the same way Isiah
Thomas in Boston has been trying to do
it I mean players they do this but this
is the a formal chance just like last
year again I go back to the altars thing
in the room for San Antonio influential
was the presence of Kawhi Leonard and
Tim Duncan and even Patty Mills who had
a relationship with LaMarcus Aldridge
that dates back to his Portland days
being in the room with him as these
presentations go forward this has the
potential to have a much bigger impact
than just a at a practice or an all-star
game
say hey man you need to come play for us
he's Chris Mannix from yahoo sports
their special tonight the vertical
that'll be at eleven-thirty Easterns
that we get ready for the start of free
agency what about Dwayne Wade you know
this is eerily reminiscent of what we
dealt with a couple of years ago with
Dwayne the the one thing that Duane
wants to get across to Miami this is
what I'm told is that he's not taking
any kind of hometown discount or any
kind of pay cut if it means trying to
create space to bring in marginal stars
right in other words you're not getting
Dwayne to leave a couple of million
dollars on the table so you can go out
and get a Kent Bazemore now if you say
that Kevin Durant is going to come play
from Miami that I think Duane will will
play with his salary a little bit
because he wants to win over the final
few years of his career but his people
have kind of created this market out
there for Dwyane Wade as sort of a
threat I think to Miami saying you know
look we're going to look at new york la
all these cities that are out there it
just as a you know as a president word
of warning to Pat Riley that this is not
going to be business as usual with
Dwyane Wade he'll help you out with the
big stars but if it Kylie's not to help
you all with these lesser guys the
market for Dwight Howard is what you
know I might be the only one in the
world that thinks it's going to be
robust I do I think that Dwight is going
to have half a dozen to a dozen teams
that are looking to find him now it's
not going to happen quickly because
Dwight Howard he needs to see what the
markets gonna bear out for him because
he's going to go into free agency
thinking all right my priority is a four
year max deal it might take him a two or
three days to figure out that deal is
just not on the table then you get down
to those second tier of offers and
what's the strongest second tier offer
what does Portland come in with what is
Boston come in with what does it lanta
come in with at that point I think
Dwight shoesies from the best available
offer i mean i wouldn't hesitate for a
second n to give Dwight Howard two years
at 50 million three years at 65 70 I
still think that's white at 30 years old
can be a productive player for the next
three
be an 18-point 12 rebounds type of guy
if that's what would get it done with
Dwight Howard I would give him that deal
of 1201 well if I can do 18 and 12 with
him and he can be a defensive presence
then you know I understand it but we are
sort of shying away from big men at
least you know his kind of big man has
done and tell tell Golden State that at
the end of the finals when they were
getting run over by Tristan tops how
badly did they need Andrew Bogut over
those last two games I don't buy that i
buy the game is evolving I don't buy
that a big man with the ability to
dominate like Dwight Howard i thik still
does is is going out of style but would
you rather have Joakim Noah or Dwight
Howard uh I think it's close I think for
the Knicks I'd rather Joakim Noah
because he doesn't want the ball and
he's okay playing a certain style but I
think for Portland and for Boston I
prefer Dwight Howard yeah I like
Portland is opinion he needs to go to a
smaller market I think and he also needs
to go where he knows he's going to touch
the ball it is he going to touch the
ball with those shooting guards in
Portland is he going to touch the ball
with those young kids in Boston I think
he touched the ball wat in Boston
frankly that's obviously seen them I'm
really familiar with but you know Brad
Stevens is maybe the smartest coaching
basketball and if he's not he's in the
top three and Brad Stevens will find a
way to get to white his touches I mean
do I have to go into these teams in with
an understanding that they're not
finding him to be their franchise player
yes yes the gwynt understanding that
yeah his shots are going to go off from
the eight and a half per game he said
last season in Houston but they're not
going to go up to 17 18 per game and
he's averaging 25 26 be the ultimate
thing with Dwight that's that no one
really knows right now but if he if he
somehow next year goes into his team and
understands he's the second or third
option he can be a fantastic addition to
them if he goes in thinking I need to be
the man then that's going to lead to
problems who's the guy who gets a max
deal that we all say huh oh I don't know
Marvin Williams may be in charlotte um
you know Nick
for two min Harrison Barnes are going to
be right there with Matt feels min Kent
Bazemore price goes up almost by the
hour which is amazing I mean you saw it
land on draft night drafted to swing
then I think that's a pretty clear sign
from the Hawks that they're not going to
play the Kent Bazemore game and let
teams drive up the price on him but then
I can't emphasize this enough it's going
to be the Wild West over these next
couple of days I had one general manager
tell me that they had on their board
Matthew Dellavedova earmarked at like 8
million dollars per year I mean this is
this is almost almost crazy some of the
talk that's that's out there right now I
think you're going to see some head
scratching salaries over the weekend
that when you come back after the fourth
of July years to look around and say you
know what the hell happen thank you
Chris have fun tonight all right then
that's a Chris Mannix the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience